you know God close the door and then he
opens a window and my window happen to
be a giant ethnically ambiguous
punk-rock chick with big titties looking
like if the rock was a suicide girl
[Music]
welcome to this has not happened
I'm your host Roy Wood jr. nice teeth
let's have a good time
ladies microphone is all about room
[Applause]
title if these balls could talk
please give it up for my friend Louis
Katz so I've always uh always been a
very romantic guy and then at some point
something took a turn in me and I became
very cynical it's hard to pinpoint
exactly when that happened but if I take
a wild guess I say it could be July 2nd
2006 at a 53 in the morning that was
when my six-year relationship that was
supposed to end in marriage instead
ended when I found out for the last two
of those six years she was
another dude yeah it's weird figuring
out that someone you're with is cheating
on you it's kind of like solving a
murder mystery except you're the victim
I should have seen it coming all the
signs were there you know she was
distant she wasn't returning my phone
calls quickly as she used to
her tasted like dick
[Applause]
my friends were trying to cheer me up to
be like oh uh oh don't worry at least to
get some good material out of it all I
got was that tastes like dick Joe
not worth it I was I was super depressed
I couldn't stop thinking about it
I even invented my own sex move as a way
to try and get back at her kind of like
the donkey punch
or the dirty sanchez I invented my own
move I called it the vengeful Louie
here's how it works Penner girls
cheating on you but you act like
everything's cool right and he going for
the makeup sex right and then right
before he about to you pull out then
you start crying she leaves and he never
trust anyone ever again
[Applause]
being she done really hidden me
up man I was completely broken and I
thought the only way I'd ever get better
would be if I fell in love again and I
didn't think that was possible
and I was in that mindset still a year
later doing a gig in Portland Oregon and
after the show I'm looking for a place
to eat I finally found one place that's
open but sitting out front blocking the
door or two gutter punks all right one
person knows gutter punks of course
they're like you know they're like the
the young rock-and-roll homeless we've
got all the patches on their clothes and
the tats and the piercings looking like
a band that went camping and they got
super lost
he's got a dog that's somehow cleaner
than all of them and as I get close to
the door about to walk in instead ask me
for change they get up follow me into
the restaurant turns out they weren't
homeless they were the weights death
yeah I can be hard to tell in Portland
where everyone's dressed like they're in
some stage of camping
[Laughter]
so I go inside I noticed the one that's
helping me out she's actually kind of
cute I'm thinking I got to say something
cool to impress this fine ass gutter
server like like you know I'm just
traveling through town you almost and a
comedian I tour all over the place and
she's like oh that's that's really cool
I love to travel too I actually used to
hop on trains that's so funny because
when I first saw you I thought you were
homeless classic pick-up line
and believe it or not it worked I got
her number and I started talking on the
phone regularly with the most uniquely
beautiful woman I've ever met in my life
you never seen anyone like her I mean
she was nearly six feet tall part black
part white part Native American
powerful white so you see you you're
like oh she must be the first of a new
master race of Amazonian super women or
like the world's largest Filipino
plus she had all that gutter Punk style
you know with the tats and the piercings
she had purple hair and was shaved on
the side like all this is perfect you
know I could totally picture defending
my honor as we roam through a
post-apocalyptic wasteland I was amazing
as if the universe was making up for me
being cheated on by bringing me my
Dreamgirl you know God closed the door
and then he opens a window and my window
happened to be a giant ethnically
ambiguous punk rock with big
titties looking like if the rock was a
suicide girl
[Applause]
so we're talking on the phone it's that
early stage of the relationship we're
just getting to know each other it's
like every new thing I'm learning about
her just making me more and more into
her you know I found out she uh she used
to do heroin so yeah that's that's
interesting and uh she was starting to
strip like cool we both work at
nightclubs she stabbed his skinhead up
living the dream
she had a baby she's totally down to
awesome but uh between the baby and
the possible manslaughter charge I'm
thinking I should not see her anymore
so I flap to Portland see her some more
we meet up she shows up she's already
pretty drunk her sees to get drunker we
end up sleeping together but we don't
have sex cuz like I said she's very
drunk and also remembered like she's
almost six feet tall this very awkward
trying to have sex with someone that
much bigger than you know it's less of a
doggy style more of a a jockey style
so we wake up in the morning she's like
I could you could you give me a beer oh
my god okay get her a beer and chugs a
beer so could you get me another beer
alright get another beer she chugs the
beer apparently she was playing some
kind of a one-woman drinking game called
alcoholism but after chugging only two
beers she was pretty sober relatively
for her and we're having a great time
you know we're just fooling around
making each other laugh she was super
funny she always called me the one of
two things either call me toots like
some kind of Waffle House waitress named
Trixie or woman it's a funny thing to
call a dude and we're sitting there
messing around in bed and I'm just
kissing her all over and I keep kissing
her I'm not even thinking that I'm doing
it but I keep kissing her like here and
here and at one point she kind of
nonchalantly just stops me she goes hey
why are you doing that and I'd even
realize it until she said it but I was
kissing her on the scar she had from
where she tried to kill herself
I was super embarrassed at the time you
know it's I just revealed so much about
both of us we were naked but all sudden
it got way more intimate than either was
wanted to be like I mean there's so many
weird things I could have been doing in
bed with her that would have been so
much easier to explain why I was doing
if I was just perched on the edge of the
bed just flicking my nutsack so why are
you doing that well let me let me take
you to the scrotum flickr subreddit
there's a whole bunch of us we're a
community but i know how to explain why
i was kissing her suicide scars like
some kind of living Morrisey lyric i
guess i could have tried to explain
myself like i don't know
you got daddy issues I'm kissing your
boo-boos I've got to save your complex
you got wounds on your wrists I mean
isn't it obvious this is my way of
asking you will you go codependent with
me she leaves and I have this horrible
feeling in my stomach and I realize I
have fallen in love again and I knew it
was gonna end badly but to me that was
the best part you know wasn't gonna
go down like I did with the last girl
and my exit stabbed me in the back this
girl would never do that
she's standing right in the face
and yeah I knew it was gonna hurt but
after being cheated on that's what I
thought love was like it hurt you know
it wasn't all bells ringing and and and
birds chirping no that was a fantasy
that that kind of love was one of those
things that only happens in the movies
they're like like wacky food fights and
double penetration this is how real love
felt you know I mean was scary it was
painful and was gonna tear me up from
the inside like double penetration so we
uh we uh we keep having this
long-distance relationship seeing each
other on and off again over the course
of the year I would always love talking
to work so if ever I had a bad day she
would always cheer me up like I remember
this one day I was having a um I was
really struggling with this new queef
joke I was working on so I call her up
and like I really got to talk to you
she's like I really got to talk to you
too I got evicted from my apartment they
fired me for my job and they took away
my baby I can't even begin to imagine
bringing up the queef joke now that's a
lot of problems for one person deal with
but I'm like it's not a problem for me I
can solve this I can save you here's
what we're gonna do I'm gonna buy you
ticket from Portland down to LA you can
come stay with me while we put you in a
rehab and I did it right there and then
bought the tickets she flew down the
next day huge mistake because it wasn't
true she couldn't live with me because I
live with my parents kind of an unspoken
rule of my folks place don't bring home
any alcoholic stripper hobos
if they're not Jewish
[Applause]
so now we're holed up in a seedy motel
less than a mile for my parents nice
house I'm constantly paring away my
mom's gonna drive by and see us
I've sneaking her food from their
kitchen ET style or stranger things
style if you're closer to her age and
finally after about a week I find a
rehab that has roofer we put her in and
shirt's following the program and
getting better I just I just felt so
great you know it's like wow it's like a
good deed that I could and time
passes I'm not really hearing from her
sounds like she's following the program
and sobering up and I'm thinking I'll
you know this is amazing we're not
together but this is the happy ending I
was looking for then I get a call from
her she ran away from the rehab with a
street poet named trash can
now she living on the streets and she's
back on heroin yeah that's the thing
with this girl you know addicts have to
hit rock bottom before they can quit
something she would hit a rock bottom
and then drill through that rock bottom
find a new deeper shittier rock bottom
like some kind of life Frakker now I'm
getting random calls from her while
she's homeless I'm at one point trash
can calls me very charming guy I get it
make a one last call from her she calls
me up she says a trash can is dead I
don't know what to do you got to help me
like oh how'd he die she said he
said he would kill himself if I left him
and I did and he did goddamn trash can
is a man of his word I mean that's a
real romantic right there how am I
supposed to compete with that there's
enough chocolate-covered pineapple in
the world for that edible arrangement
look I don't know what you want from me
I already flew you down from Portland to
Los Angeles I struggled and fought to
get you to rehab I put you in the rehab
and still you managed to it all up
so why don't you stop calling me lose my
number and I hang up on her so drive to
pick her up
so I'm a driver to the Greyhound station
over in Hollywood get her ticket back to
Portland she can go be a homeless junkie
where she knows the bus schedule and we
get to the station but instead of
walking in to buy the ticket with me she
decides just to lie down on the ground
in the middle of the parking lot started
screaming crying and throwing a fit look
at these a Greyhound parking lot so that
kind of thing happens like every hour on
the hour
I'm standing there trying to reason with
this clearly unreasonable person and as
I'm talking to her three older
well-dressed white ladies start coming
at me and looking like Nick at Nite
mom's coming from a bake sale I was
scared of my mom catching me now I've
got three moms and they're they're
coming at us fast and they're asking
questions in a typical mom fashion you
know what I mean like like like
concerned but also a dash of disapproval
on top there first I get kind of
defensive like look can't a man attempt
to abandon a young girl in a ground
parking lot don't judge
but they seem like they actually wanted
to help you know that the checking her
vitals and and making sure she stays
conscious and stuff like that so I'm
thinking like oh maybe maybe they're
nurses and and one of you pulls me aside
and goes like this is you know this is
really serious we've got to get her out
of her quick because if we don't and the
psychiatrists are gonna come and they're
gonna pump her full of drugs yeah I was
just worried about getting on the bus I
didn't know we had to look out for
psychiatrist street gangs whose turf is
this the Freudian Crips or the young
jung geun's
finally I put it together in my head
irrational fear psychiatry we're in
Hollywood they're not nurses they're
Scientologists anyway they didn't come
from a bake sale that came from praying
as he knew the galactic Overlord all
praises due upon him no disrespect still
trying to make him show business nothing
like I don't know maybe Scientology
would be a good option for her she ever
quit heroin she'll need two equally
time-consuming hobby maybe Tom Cruise
will come through and save the day the
originator of jockey style
[Applause]
and then at one point even these nice
ladies are like we don't know what else
we can do for they're like we're gonna
call 9-1-1 I'm like wait don't do that I
get down on my knees start whispering
right in your ear I like saying look to
its stop around they're gonna
call the police I don't want you to go
to jail please get up right now and as
I'm talking to her
her head gets heavy in my hand I can't
find a pulse and she doesn't seem to be
breathing so they call 9-1-1 an
ambulance comes screaming into the
parking lot somehow they managed to
revive her as soon as she comes to
shirts kicking and screaming freaking
out even worse than before it takes two
large EMT guys to restrain her and they
strap it down to the gurney and they're
pushing her into the ambulance and
there's tears of mascara pouring down
her face and before that they close the
doors on like look touch please just
listen to the doctors do what they say
you'll get better she goes I'm never
getting better it just kind of knocks
the wind out of me because I realize you
know what maybe she's right
no maybe she's never getting better
because maybe nobody ever really gets
better you know I thought if I fixed her
with it would fix me but I couldn't do
it I wish I could but I I wish I knew
how I wish there was some kind of
instruction manual for fixing people and
the amylum strives off and one of the
ladies comes up to me with a kind look
in her eyes and she says have you ever
read Dianetics
[Applause]
that was the moment I stopped being a
romantic thank you very much tonight
[Applause]